voici chami et bibi naceri
5000 et bibi nacéri bonsoir donc c'est
ton frère
c'est ouais c'est mon grand frère on a
beaucoup entendu parler de vous mais
voilà c'est la première fois qu'on vous
voit on est ravis libye mais aussi alors
vous êtes là parce que sorti le 23
octobre d'un film très attendu qui
s'appelle la mentale scénario du
réalisateur manuel boursinhac avec vous
bibi naceri à l'affiché à vous ça me à
samuel le bihan et à clotilde courau il
ya marie guilard il ya michel duchaussoy
voilà alors j'explique le titre la
mental c'est un code d'honneur en fait
la mental que les voyous s'impose entre
c'est ça oui mais je veux dire il peut
s'adapter à tout le monde il peut
s'adapter à thierry ardisson il peut
s'adapter à lyon la latte et les
avantages well et je veux dire après ça
va un peu plus haut chez les voyous
c'est bien se tenir à la police prendre
15 ans de prison est pas envoyer ses
collègues en prison c'est les dix
commandements un peu de l'emile
commandement des voyous tu ne feras pas
tu ne feras pas là mental je veux savoir
se taire protéger sa famille ne jamais
trahir c'est une espèce de de code
d'honneur ancestrale des des truands
ça ça remonte à très loin vers oui à la
cour des miracles il avait déjà cessé
code d'honneur qui sont plus ou moins
respecté
mais est ce assez transmis de génération
en génération
oui à la fois à la fois ils avaient bien
il s'est vu obligé de les respecter
puisqu'elle a la sanction était
tellement sévère qu alors vous tous les
deux quand vous étiez moma à
fontenay-sous-bois montreuil plutôt que
de dîner du shit ou boire des bières
vous fréquentiez des mecs de l'emec de
40 ans qui avait des ce genre de règles
morales déjà pour commencer et puis qu
avec des belles caisses des beaux
costards vous étiez quand même assez
intéressé par ce milieu là déjà
on était envieux nous on était jeunes et
on les voyait avec leur bm avec des
belles filles dans les voitures mettre
des bouteilles dans les boîtes à billets
bien habillés et on les enviais on les
voyait mais on savait qu'ils qu'ils
avaient choisi et que d'un côté il y
avait la police et d'un côté il y avait
eu il avait choisi d'être marginaux et
il savait qu'au bout du compte c'était
soit de finir dans un caniveau et au
mieux finir en prison
donc il avait choisi il se cachait pas
ils revendiquaient c'était des voyous
pour se cacher pas derrière un costume
et une cravate mais surtout il nous
ressemble et nous on était des mondes
qui avec et plus qui étaient pas très
bon à l'école en effet ces banques et
aux fonds de temps en temps il ya un
psychologue il orienta terre qui venait
dire qu'on n'était pas très tellement
intelligent et qu'on dirait pas très
loin dans la vie et puis cela on avait
10 à 2 puis il avait fait un parcours
peut-être dans la marge mais un parcours
qui nous paraissaient tu ne réussit pas
mal alors le pitch du film ça peut se
résumer en une phrase si on n'échappe
pas à son destin d'une certaine façon sa
meilleure façon de le résumer alors
c'est l'histoire de samuel le bihan qui
sort de taule après quatre ans qui veut
se ranger des voitures
il veut vivre tranquillement avec avec
une fille sérieuse et puis se dit bon là
mentale justement et puis trop respecté
par les par les voyous quoi donc il veut
il veut décrocher il veut décrocher du
truc
mais au nom de la mental justement ça me
voue son cousin vous lui demander de
revenir dans la bande
oui parce que c'est mon double c il a
fait quatre ans de prison on était jeune
aujourd'hui on tient le pavé parisien
on a tous pendant les quatre ans qu'il
était en prison nous on a continué à
construire on l'a assistée et moi sans
lui je suis perdue c'est mon double et
je le vois travailler comme un comme un
fou et nous on a on a monté un empire et
on est respecté par tout le monde on
gagne de l'argent assez facilement on a
des clés de toutes les portes toutes les
portes s'ouvrent tout le monde nous
respecte
et j'ai envie qu'ils viennent avec nous
qu'ils gagnent de l'argent facilement il
ya une scène qui a été coupée dans le
film où je lui demande juste de prendre
une paire de jumelles de se mettre sur
une montagne de surveiller il va toucher
500 bâton et ils refusent ils refusent
ils refusent
jusqu'au jour où
où il va craquer comme beaucoup de mecs
qui sortent de prison et qu'on rien et
qu'on revient dans les mains qu'on pas
de travail parce qu'ils ont un casier
judiciaire et quand les les chefs
d'entreprise tape officier qui voyait
qu'ils ont fait 15 ans de prison
on les engage pas alors qu'il a fait des
connaissances en prison et y retrouve
hiva rue lauriston il va à belleville il
va place clichy et il retrouve ses
anciens potes et replonge bien une
phrase aussi qui résume assez bien la
situation si tu peux pas tourner le dos
à des mecs avec qui tu as grandi c'est
difficile pour lui parce que par rapport
à vous de ne pas accepter c'est
lamentable justement non mais à la fois
c'est un non sens parce que lui là il a
vécu il a vécu dans un monde où l'argent
était facile ou c'étaient des seigneurs
ou été respectée où il est où il était
quelqu un vaccin qui se retrouve avec
les masala à ramasser des pommes de
terre je veux dire le fossé il est
tellement énorme que peut-être que s'il
avait eu des capacités autres et puis
qui valut un bon job il arrêté dans le
cinéma où il ne s'est pas éteinte et
jaurès il qui va replonger